sow
ça ça m'a fait plaisir
le gaye sarr était là en voiture mal et
j'ai des courses pour la ramener deux
sacs
on m'a dit ça c'est un monde à part de
ma femme ça ça m'aide à part de ma
belle-mère pratiquement toujours je fus
et je fais la revue de presse de 3,6
journaux tout ce qui est scientifique
tout ce qui est social social justice
violations des droits de l'homme à 60
balais devant les tchèques ont remonté
la pente pour trouver primer sur les
mauvaises choses
il peut encore y avoir les bonnes choses
qu'est ce que vous faites comme vous
avez froid je grelotte
l'offre quatre ans il ya des matins je
me lève et j'en ai vraiment marre à fond
chaque fois qu'elle le marathon de paris
qui secours moi je cours le marathon
paris si encore on pouvait vraiment se
mettre quelque part mais on dérange
toujours
tout comme s'il considérait pas ce que
tu es là tout est fini pour toi c'est
même plus la peine de s'arrêter c'est
même plus la peine d'écouter la non
réponse aux problèmes qui nous maintient
ici c'est ça le pire
une si belle neige revient